a protests are being held across France
after unions called for a nationwide
strike major disruptions to transport
are expected as many trains and buses
have been canceled workers in the
governments are deadlocked and calling
for higher wages to counter a growing
cost of living crisis or counts at all
Depots have also sparked fuel shortages
Let's cross straight away to Paris
Natasha Butler is standing by there at
the square where protesters are due
together so Natasha there will be a
demonstration later tell us more about
what's going to happen
yes workers are due to gather here in a
few hours to demand better pay better
working conditions many of them very
worried indeed about how they're going
to cope in the coming months because of
inflation mainly we'll see workers from
the transport sector with also energy
workers including oil refinery workers
now many of them have been on strike now
for a month locked in the standoff with
their bosses at a total energy total
energy have offered uh pay Rises to some
workers but the Hardline cgt Union here
in France says that pay rise simply
isn't enough there's also a lot of anger
amongst workers about the fact that many
large companies particularly these
energy companies have made huge profits
recently because of the energy crisis
and there is a sense that those profits
that money should be shared around with
the workers and how much disruption has
all this caused so far
well the trade unions had called for a
general strike a nationwide uh walkout
but look that has not happened because
many sectors simply haven't taken part
we don't have the health sector uh
education sector as I said really mainly
uh transport and energy sectors
nevertheless that has caused some
disruption for people who are mainly
trying to get around because half of the
regional train Services have been cut
and some bus services the Metro here in
Paris they probably see the bridge
behind me that is uh still running
without any problems as are the
Intercity lines nevertheless so this
does add to uh the difficulty for many
people who are commuting getting around
the country because we've had that fuel
shortage now for a few weeks so anyone
wanting to use a vehicle is still
finding it very hard indeed to fill up
their car or their motorbike because a
third of the petrol stations in France
are still suffering a fuel shortage the
government has issued an order to force
some key oil refinery staff back to work
it doesn't seem to have made much of a
difference at the petrol pump yet but
it's certainly infuriated trade unions
and that's part of the reason that they
called for this strike action today
all right Natasha thanks for that back
with you as the day progresses Natasha
Butler there in Paris